If I don’t think the future
is worth anything
then I'm not going to have children.
If I think it is worth something,
I will have children.
We are already seeing
coastal city flooding,
we're already seeing forest fires,
we're already seeing flash floods,
we're seeing tornadoes.
When big ecological disasters
happen around the world,
I feel a sense of anxiety.
I feel a sense of sadness
and a sense of loss.
So imagine you go outside
and you look up in the sky,
and there's a comet there.
And you know - you've just
been told by scientists
that that comet
is racing toward the Earth
and it's going to kill everybody
and everything in a big fiery storm.
And nobody else notices the comet.
And you say: "Hey look,
there's a comet and it's
going to kill all of us..."
And people just don’t seem to care.
Climate change anxiety as a term
is a relatively new term.
By no way a new phenomenon.
It's an anxiety that
is about the future.
And a trauma that we haven't
experienced yet,
but that we know is going to
come our way.
We're facing a very existential fear.
This is not a fear about how
does my body look?
Or am I popular enough?
This is a fear about our survival.
What is it that makes you anxious?
What are the thoughts or what are
the details that when you go there
that's when you touch your anxiety.
In other parts of the world,
they'll be more affected
by climate change
than the cities that
we currently live in.
That's when I feel like...
we're not doing enough.
One of the most
sort of potent anxieties,
is the fear of...
people mistreating each other
out of panic and fear
and, you know...
it's more maybe how people
respond to that.
I just keep thinking about...
a small child.
Probably myself.
And I just think about how
innocent my -
god I'm emotional already.
That memory I have of being a child,
that is so valuable.
And I just think about all the people
that aren't... That don't have that.
That preciousness about the world
and I think that’s really...
That's a privilege
that is just disappearing.
Yeah I get emotional
when I think about...
the effects that climate change
and its related issues will have.
I get very angry about those,
I feel very powerless.
I feel very frustrated.
I think we need more and more
people to wake up to this
and anxiety is part of the way
of digesting the information,
there's no way around that.
What is the part that you can play
in stretching out
and mending the part of the world
that is within your reach?
In the face of constant defeat,
just stubbornness and tenacity.
Understand what your impact
as a human being
is on the planet.
I feel so helpless but...
But so empowered by that helplessness
that I then want to try
and do everything and so.
We see and an unprecedented
amount of people
who present with anxiety
that they can't even locate.
And I'm wondering whether this is
that people are actually picking up
that something is not right.
I don't think it's all...
I have to believe it's not all bad.
Maybe things will be fixed
by the time they're an adult
and it will be all good.
I feel the most hopeful
when I remind myself
how bad humans have always
been at predicting the future.
Thanks for watching ;)
Don't forget to subscribe and click the bell to receive notifications for new videos. See you again soon!